throughout the course students will get
an understanding of opportunities and
limitations of machine learning in the
context of basic and translational
biomedical research projects for
pre-clinical and clinical applications
not only is this a lot of data but it's
also data that is highly variable there
are many different formats and platforms
for data generation making it extremely
heterogeneous one key technology driving
this explosion and data is omix comics
technologies like next generation
sequencing can be used to explore the
roles relationships and actions of the
various types of molecules that make up
the cell of an organism to analyze such
data novel computational technologies
have been developed that are
transforming life sciences enabling
biotechnology and empowering biomedical
reasons as a result researchers are
making new discoveries every day
understanding this data the technologies
used to produce it and techniques for
its analysis are now critical to
understand for anyone across the whole
life cycle of data from lab technicians
to data scientists and decisions